[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Yep.
That's me on a pig
hunt in Hawaii.
But this isn't
exactly how it looks.
SPEAKER 2: Pig right there.
SPEAKER 1: I'm actually doing
this to save coral reefs.
Let me explain.
I came to the Big
Island of Hawaii
to understand how feral pigs
along with climate change
are contributing to the
destruction of coral reefs
here.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHAD WIGGINS:
What's happening is
the pigs are up
Mauka in the forest,
and they're foraging up there
for worms and for snails.
And so they dig up the soil.
Once the rains come,
intermittently, and flood
these streams, that's when we
get a big pulse of sediment
out onto the reed.
As soon as sediment
covers the coral,
the coral typically dies.
If it's smothered, it
can't get sunlight.
It can't get oxygen. It can't
get nutrients and it's dead.
If the coral manages to survive,
every time the waves comes,
it gets re-suspended
and the sediment
continues to do damage,
sometimes for decades.
KYLE THIERMANN: Last year,
the Big Island of Hawaii
experienced the
largest coral bleaching
event in recorded history.
Right now, I'm on a
boat with scientists
from the division of
aquatic resources and NOAA
to survey the current
state of coral.
Even to my untrained eye,
I can see that the decaying
coral had lost their vibrancy.
And there were
significantly fewer fish.
LINDSEY KRAMER: To actually
see these huge multi hundred
or many hundreds of
year old colonies
completely bleached and stressed
and with that good chance
that they weren't
going to survive,
it was really devastating.
Really awful to see.
And I think, that
was the first time,
for me, that the magnitude
of this was obvious.
That we might not see
recovery from this event
in our lifetimes.
DR. JAMIE GOVE: Coral reefs
are important for a number
of reasons.
There's no other ecosystem
on this planet that
occupies such a
small geographic area
but it has more forms of life
than coral reef ecosystems.
There are unprecedented.
One in four of all
marine organisms
live in association
with coral reefs
but they occupy less than
1/10 of 1% of the sea floor.
SPEAKER 1: This is Dr. Jamie
Gove, a research oceanographer
for the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration.
He also lets me
sleep on his couch.
DR. JAMIE GOVE: So
without coral reefs,
all of those waves and
storms and currents
would reach shore
and wreak havoc
on all of the shoreline
property that we saw today,
among other things.
SPEAKER 1: Since feral
pigs are contributing
to the damage we saw underwater,
I met up with Chad back
on dry land to
see how fencing is
helping to control the problem.
CHAD WIGGINS: Once a fence is
constructed in a priority area
where you want to conserve
the forest or retain sediment,
hunters can come in and
reduce the populations.
SPEAKER 1: It's
important to note
that the eradication of feral
pigs is not the goal here.
In fact, pigs are extremely
significant to the islands.
Historically and culturally.
CHAD WIGGINS: When pigs
and goats were dropped off
by Captain Cook in 1778,
they found paradise here.
Domestic pig bread
with the Polynesian pig
which was already here at
the time of the arrival.
The facts that pigs were here
when Captain Cook arrived,
means that the
Polynesians valued
them enough to bring them
across the ocean to Hawaii
and cultivate them.
SPEAKER 1: And pigs are still
highly valued by locals here.
The problem is, their
population has exploded.
You would have to remove 70%
of the current pig population
each year to keep
them under control,
which is why people like Justin
Lee and Wayne [? Cypriano ?]
are still hunting pigs.
JUSTIN LEE: Without
hunters, without people
regulating the
numbers, Hawaii as we
know it will never be the same.
All of the useful
meat from this animal
is going to be made into
appetizers at a baby first luau
or a wedding.
It will be food on the table,
not just for our family
but for a lot of
different families.
SPEAKER 1: And Justin
makes a good argument,
which is why I found
myself on this hunt.
Climate change is endangering
coral reefs all over the world.
And our ability to deal
with land based intox,
like feral pig, could
make the difference
in the survival of these reefs.
Are you aware of other
invasive species impacting
the environment where you live?
Let us know in the
comments below.
And check out this next episode
on another island in Hawaii
where one company is growing
algae to power airplanes
and more.
SPEAKER 3: So this is
the dried algae product.
After we dry it, we
grind up into powder.
And then we extract
the oil out of it.
That oil is then refined
into diesel fuel or jet fuel.
The fuel that we're
producing is exactly the same
in terms of performance as
gasoline or diesel or jet.
It's just a lot cleaner.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks for
washing Seeker Stories
and be sure to subscribe
for new videos every week.